so let me start by saying uh congrats on
the show i just watched the first
episode uh and i think it does i'm i'm
really happy that they're aiming star
trek at kids i think it's about time um
for both of you
uh can you sort of talk about getting to
be part of a show like this that is
introducing this to a whole new
generation
yeah i was saying earlier it feels quite
extraordinary that this hasn't happened
yet when they told me this is the first
time i was like really thought
well it's great to be a part of it it
feels like a really like iconic moment
in star trek history i have younger
brothers and
i feel really proud that this is the
kind of content that they get to see and
they get to be consuming now um i think
the messages
of star trek are timeless can be applied
to any age any generation and on top of
the fact that like it's a beautiful
whimsical fun
you know ex extent of your imagination
or um
come and think of the word but you know
it's fun you get to be a kid you're like
completely immersed in this world
totally and i completely agree i
remember growing up and watching all of
my favorite animated series uh
specifically nickelodeon like i loved
avatar the last airbender and i just
wanted that
all the time to be like the thing i was
watching and sort of looking up to i
would like
like
in my sink try to like make the water
move and so um it's awesome to be able
to know that we're giving this to kids
in this gorgeous cinematic animation and
that this is what they will get to grow
up sort of
watching and learning the themes of and
and implying the lessons that they're
learning from this to their everyday
lives at school and in their social
situations as they grow up um so it's
awesome to be a part of bringing that to
to a younger audience feels
almost like you know getting to sort of
plant a seed in someone's mind of of the
next thing the next generation
oh i like the way you tied that into
next generation star trek you know that
was very very almost on purpose right
exactly um also it doesn't hurt that at
some point you could be action figures
as your characters oh absolutely you
know that's not i want to be as big as
the one behind you
listen i think that even though i'm just
gonna say this and even though they're
not gonna say it but i do think this is
also a way for uh for paramount and
viacom to sell toys to kids you got to
make the show to
you know sell merchandise the backpacks
all yes all of it we want all the merch
by the way like that anyway that's a
whole separate thing um but were you
guys actually star trek fans before
signing on i know it's a little generic
or did you sort of like um
like binge everything or binge a whole
bunch once you got the role
i knew nothing i watched nothing
wait it
it worked fine
it did right we're here now and that's
what matters
did you actually see anything
of star trek oh oh sorry me hi
um no i also didn't see anything and in
a way it kind of worked because i didn't
get too attached to ways of doing things
like i kind of managed to bring my own
uh spin on things and
you know modernize it and make it
something that kids now will love and
find funny and all of that stuff um
so yeah we're i'm just a very committed
actor who's very method and i'm just
deeply attached to my craft absolutely
same
and i'm glad now knowing jumping in that
i'm glad i didn't look it up because i
would have been really really
intimidated
did you as you've recorded further in
the process of making the series um have
you sort of felt more ownership of your
characters and maybe like as they give
you a line you almost say you know i
think he or she would say it like this
you know what i mean
yeah that's definitely something that's
developed over time the collaborative
processing first couple sessions i was
super intimidated and and was learning
the character you know they had been
working with her for so long that it it
was only right for me to be the one
asking questions and then as we've
developed her together as a team now it
feels like i can be like oh this could
be a really hey do you guys want to
incorporate this element this could be a
really fun way to make her seem more
this or to drop these little seeds in
and you know improvising slightly i'm
not a great improviser but sometimes
um yeah things like that it's been fun
to collaborate
a hundred percent the same experience
for me i was very much like very curious
about him at the beginning asking lots
of questions even sometimes going back
and they were having us
well at least me specifically like redo
certain lines and things because it's
like okay he's leaning a bit this way
what about if we try it like this or you
know give different options for how to
make this
the most like uh
easy to understand and and true to what
they were thinking for the characters so
over time you do definitely gain
ownership and they're so like the
creative team is just so incredible and
they're so totally open to moments of
improvisation and uh pre-lap lines and
just
life in the middle of your
scenes and things like that they're
they're really receptive to those things
and um they they throw the ball in my
cord a lot i we have this running joke
that i'm associate writing assistant um
production assistant for dal because
there's been so many things that they've
allowed me to improvise that's awesome
um i gotta stop there i'm just gonna say
i really hope you're almost done with
interviews and you know uh
yeah good luck with i was gonna say good
luck with the speed dating um have a
fantastic afternoon thank you so much
thank you